hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
first update of our $10,000 linkedin
challenge and the idea here is to make
an additional ten thousand dollars in
income only from using LinkedIn and the
idea here came from a woman named
Christina Jeremy low I was being
interviewed by her husband who runs a
really successful b2b marketing radio
show and we were talking about all the
different social media networks and
although all the work i do on twitter
and facebook and youtube and we talked
about linkedin and i said that i wasn't
really getting much value from linkedin
of all the social media networks
linkedin was probably the least value or
is getting some i was giving the least
value from linkedin and when linkedin
was you know when it first came out i
was really active on it and for a while
we could show you exactly how many
people were in your serperior
connections and it would even showed you
how you rank in your country and I was
the eighth or ninth most connected
person in Canada and I was you know
really active on it and I just stopped
because I wasn't getting any value from
it wasn't getting a lot of website
visitors it wasn't getting people
converting to my site and so I stopped
you know part of my methodology here is
as an entrepreneur you want to try
things on a small scale see if it works
if it works you continue with its are
investing more time and money into and
if it doesn't work you stop and so I
wasn't getting the value when I stopped
while I continued the other social media
networks with more success and Christina
and her husband were both saying you
know we got a we got to get on linkedin
there's a lot of value here for you and
let's try this challenge where we're
going to try to get you an extra ten
thousand dollars in business and new
business only using LinkedIn and so I
said okay I'm up for the challenge is
he'll we can do and I'm going to I'm
starting from the ground up here and
it's going to walk you through kind of
step by step what I do to earn that new
business and hopefully these guys can
help deliver on their promise so
christina has a great profile here in
New York Times recognized social media
expert help the client gained six
thousand dollars and immediate profits
and for me to interviews with LinkedIn
that's a great case study hopefully I
was going to say ten thousand dollars in
the media profits and the website that
they would work on is get linkedin help
so perfect people to talk to I guess if
I'm trying to
boost my LinkedIn profile so in terms of
what we've done this is just the first
update that's still very early stages
and not sure if they want me making this
video yet because we haven't officially
had our first talk about it but I like
getting started early so we'll see how
it goes the very first thing that we did
was improve the profile and if you look
at my profile it's basically making a
lot more action oriented so you have
your name and also something about you
in your profile with a little line here
and a call to action right away in your
profile so minus attention brain so
promote your company to my online
audience of over 14 million business
owners and then also basically updating
your your background information to make
it more of a sales pitch make it more
action-oriented you can read it if you
check my profile out if you want with a
call to action and basically that's
that's that's a start so my the goal
here is to attract brands so we're
working with clients like they'll tell
us an american express and helping them
reach more entrepreneurs and so we're
looking for more brains to partner with
and that's how we're trying to get that
extra ten thousand dollars in revenue so
that's kind of step 1 the next step is
to create my own group and i have just
created my own group and i have sent it
over to the team but having heard boxes
it's still kind of the first day so not
a lot happening on the group yet let me
load it up so you can see what we're
doing so created a new group called
marketing the small business and we
still don't have a logo or anything yet
so this is very early days as you can
see and i posted something here and the
idea here is the post regular value
added content the goal here is to
attract people who are in my niche it's
not going after everybody it's for
people who are trying to market to small
business owners and that's why we named
it marking the small businesses and so
I'm really targeting brain so I don't
want a thousand or million people sign
it up for this group I just want the
people who are my potential target
audience that was the suggestion and so
then the next step is creating ongoing
value ID content in the group to
encourage people to want to join and be
an active participant so the first one
was what makes a perfect tweet and this
is basically where I'm sharing from a
brand's point of view what makes a good
tweet and
share some examples of some that are
great some that are good and some that
are failed so not not good tweets at all
and so kind of best practices to learn
from and then you know what do you think
and it looks like somebody's already
commented on it so John McQuillan thanks
John new connection I guess here and I
just wrote back to say glad he enjoyed
so very early days of the group this is
our first real post on it and again the
goal here is to get ten thousand dollars
a new business through LinkedIn only not
using other methods and as we go along
our way I will keep you guys posted with
what what we're doing and give you more
ideas on how you can use the same
strategies to grow your business through
LinkedIn I have a call set with
Christina tomorrow and so hopefully
we'll get some more ideas and get some
feedback on the group and hopefully she
doesn't tell me that launches video too
soon but I kind of wanted to get you
guys in on the ground floor and we'll
keep you posted as you go if you guys
like this idea and you want to see more
videos and more updates then please give
it a thumbs up below that's how we know
you're interested and if you have a
question about this video or a question
about your own linkedin group myself and
Christina will be checking out all the
comments that do come in so feel free to
leave one below and then we'd be happy
to try to answer any questions that do
come in so thank you and hopefully we'll
have a good update for you soon